hallo mein name ist luca und ihr kennt
man da mal herzlich willkommen am
freitag zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft ich bin immer noch kranke
angeschlagen meine stimme hört sich an
wie die eines ich wollte ich war wir wir
fangen an ich befinde mich auf dem hd
dot net server in der survival games
lobby ich weiß wie du werden denken
lokal das ja so was von 2013 dass das so
weil wir eben sox mittlerweile machen
die ganzen coolen youtuber eigene
projekte ich bin einfach so ein kleiner
voll spaßte einfach noch survival games
alleine zockt ja was habe ich mir dabei
gedacht dass ich hier stehe er mich
schon immer erst mal ganz kurz den
liegenden lobby rein hier dann 14 17 von
20 dann noch hallo herr vielleicht eine
art geht direkter ich befinde mich hier
in der survival games lobby weil ich
habe mir gedacht ja im titel
ortsgemeinschaft jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon gesehen und denke ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich so habt ihr überhaupt ton
ich weiß nicht wenn die kantone ab tut
mir leid aber ich glaube ihr habt also
ja es geht mir darum so ein bisschen das
ich jetzt hier zum beispiel gamestop ist
jetzt hier der grund weil das war dann
so von mir gedacht dass ich dann das 4
farbig luc abalo auf dauer toll da kann
man zwei steaks das ist da dass es super
dass du heiliger fig ihr beiden da ihr
könntet vielleicht einfach von mir
absehen und euch gegenseitig töten
das wäre sehr schön dann kann ich
einfach mal komme hier ist versteckten
kießler ich habe mir gedacht ich mach
mal wieder so ein oldschool minecraft
runde so wie es früher gemacht
wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt mein gott oh
mein gott ich bin komplett kryptischer
was ist das bitte also ich hab mein gott
ich bin ich bin tatsächlich holt gerade
vielleicht noch länger klatschen ich
habe mir gedacht ich mach mal wieder so
eine typische
mannschaft zu beide games runde
oldschool mäßig wie es früher gemacht
habe und zwar habe ich früher einmal pvp
genutzt um zu labern deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich mach jetzt auch so dass
ich quasi einfach mal so ein bisschen
durchlaufen wir hier dann so wieder ganz
oldschool kommentiere so wir haben ja
sogar die schuhe aber beschwerde hatte
ich gucke nach oben hier so eine kiste
cola will ja auch noch alle sachen die
ich mit die hier an oder buggy de niro
dann habe ich ein schwert und einer rose
wunderschöne auf rose reimt sich rose
und nach hose reimt sich luca haye kommt
vielleicht zurück zum thema durchaus
spannend ja ich weiß nicht ich hab ihn
nie vermisst zu labern einfach in serien
deswegen das ist ja mittlerweile in der
in der aktuellen zeit musste alles sehr
schnell gehen und ich schneide ja meine
videos auch immer so dass die so ein
bisschen so sehr sehr also oh mein gott
oh mein gott der wiso leute denn direkt
auf mich auf mich zuläuft aber noch
wieso auch hier habe ich so gemacht dass
ich in cyber games raum gelagert habe
was in der schule abging und ich habe
mich auch sehr auf beschwert darüber wie
wenig zeit ich habe und ich glaube das
hat sich bis heute nicht verändert dass
gerade so bei mir ab geht es halt ich
bin krank ich habe mich irgendwie weiß
ich nicht irgendwie glaube ich bei einer
freundin angeht steckt in ich war wir
sind spontan bauer das muss ich euch
erzählen alte auch auf wilden youtube
video machen wo ich rüber ganz normal
erzähle wies vonstatten geht in meinem
leben und dann kommen hier nur leute an
und denken sich hier ja war toll
heute ist gerade mittwoch ich habe mir
am sonntag weil ich auf schalke gegen
revierderby und am montag hab ich mir
dann gedacht auch gott ich habe die
letzten tage mal so viel erlebt und
heute geht einfach nichts außer ein
bisschen uni unseren keller kamen kumpel
oder dachten wir ja eine komplett
wenigstens mal irgendwie beachbar fahren
so ein bisschen was man ihnen die 22
grad oh mein gott man faktisch doch
irgendwelche anderen menschen die
vielleicht gut sind aber nicht die
kleinen bescheuerten leute die das erste
mal in ihrem leben minecraft pvp spiel
okay sie können tatsächlich jeden boxen
rittner ihr match ist eine ganz normale
alte runde wieder neue ganz friedliche
schön was über ein thema erzählt das
meine ich nämlich ist es alles so
schnelllebig geworden wenn man das ist
achter assist wick survival games jetzt
spielen wir mal richtig ist weil games
meine damen und herren
also wir hatten uns am montag hat
gedacht wir gehen eine schöne biete ich
habe den ball aber nicht getroffen
wir gehen eine schöne beachbar
allerdings wo wir dann hingefahren bin
ich schon viel zu schmecken ist traurig
wie schlecht die bildung der mann auf
dem weg dahin schilder gesehen wo
flughafen dran stand unter namen wie der
ball wie fresh das wäre es sind zwar
gerade 22 grad aber in barcelona sind es
locker 28 grad wie cool das mal wenn man
einfach hin vielen könnten uns halt alle
angeschaut und achten sowie cool wenn
wir einfach hin fliegen würden und dann
sind wir wirklich einfach zum flughafen
gefahren und dann mal gefragt was sind
die nächsten ziele mallorca barcelona
rom
aber es lag alles irgendwie bei 400 euro
nur der hinflug und da muss man eher das
bringt nichts deswegen haben wir dann
gedacht okay du bist jetzt auf jeden
fall etwas erleben war kennt ihr das
vielleicht wenn man sich abends schon so
sagt so nachmittags die ganze zeit mit
freunden jahr heute abend feiern sondern
wo bin ich vielleicht mal jemand sagen
ich bin tot wenn ihr nachmittags in der
schule seit und ihr sagt ja heute abend
geht eine krasse partie voll bock und
sohn erfahrt ihr auch einmal dass die
party doch nicht geht dann geht ihr
trotzdem nie was zusammen machen
deswegen wir uns dann gedacht okay der
flug geht jetzt nicht das geht nicht
klar dass wir irgendwo hinfliegen
spontan deswegen lass uns doch trotzdem
das unternehmen deswegen sind wir
spontan nach maastricht gefahren um
mehrere alte schulfreunde von uns
studieren wollen dann haben wir die dort
besucht und wandern da noch zusammen
feiern und haben wir quasi die stadt
maastricht so ein bisschen entdeckt und
es war auch ultra cool alles vorab jetzt
hier was ein fakt ob gott ich dachte es
gestern gewesen sind nach maastricht
gefahren und dabei aber irgendwie in
holland und dann sind wir halt dann auch
irgendwie jetzt verbrenne ich sogar und
er sammelt schaden war halt in holland
sind wir schuld da hingefahren und damit
bei ihnen irgendwie auf dem fußboden
wir sind alle cabrio gefahren und das
ist da habe ich mich wahrscheinlich
irgendwo auch angesteckt dann und so ich
wollte euch das zu erzählen weil damit
eine richtige witzige story war und
solche spontanen aktionen so keine
ahnung
das macht das einfach mal sind natürlich
sind geplante reisen eis und wenn man
dann so sagt er wir machen schritte
tritt und brauchen tickets für die
ganzen sehenswürdigkeiten sonst aber wir
sind einfach spontan dahin gefahren ist
war so cool und luca halt einmal deine
schwarzes interessiert einfach kaya und
da habe ich mich wohl glaube ich auch
irgendwie dann auch faktor diese das ist
doch da habe ich mich dann halt wohl
auch irgendwie angesteckt und die sache
ist ich bin jetzt samstag bei prosieben
zu sehen wenn ihr video geht es weiter
also morgen haben wenn ich bei prosieben
zu sehen bei der völkerball
meisterschaft im team er eliza razzia
und planern youtuber noch und ich bin
eigentlich immer noch kann deswegen wird
es wahrscheinlich sehr witzig weil ich
glaube dass ich am liebsten werden alle
anstecken werde und das witzige daran
ist auch noch dass ich nächste woche
eine klausur schreiben im teammanagement
präsentation machen muss und ich habe
tatsächlich ein brötchen gerade bekommen
dann muss ich noch meine praktikums
arbeit am montag abgeben und nebenbei
natürlich auch youtube videos machen und
hey
zum glück habe ich keinen stress was ist
das für ein [ __ ] alter wie mich da
wegschubsen nur weil er zu dumm ist
dieses blöde jump'n'run das zu machen
was bist du für ein mensch
oh mein gott ich will das boot hoch
lassen ja die besten boxen sich da so
gegenseitig hier im wasser nur mit der
bloßen hand und was ist denn das für ein
spaß thema an du blöder penner dachte
meine typischen zu wald games kämpfen
gegen- sondern blöd
blödmann mit der flachen hand im wasser
gott ist das anstrengend hirn es ist
doch nicht war es kann doch nicht sein
was ist denn das für eine [ __ ]
ich dachte mir schuld zuweisen games ein
bisschen entspannt reden aber ist es so
schnelllebig geworden ich komme mir klar
ich wollte euch nur erzählen wieso ich
krank bin und was das für ein cooler
spontaner trip war und wie das jetzt in
meinem leben ist und dass ich bei
prosieben zu sehen dass ich bald auch in
wien zehn treffen mache und erst mit
meinem studium motoren das wollte ich
eigentlich nur erzählt und ich dachte
ich könnte cool survival games zocken
aber das ding ist halt gegeben
ja irgendwie bin ich tatsächlich
innerhalb von einem video so circa
sieben mal gestorben
wenn euch das video trotz regen gefallen
hatte ich weiß nicht ob es das getan hat
oder wie ist das getan haben soll aber
ich wollte es wird überhaupt keinen sinn
gemacht
tut mir leid da ist das hochgeladen hat